what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk
all things marvel and mcu and hugh
jackman sent the internet into a
spiraling frenzy yesterday posting to
his instagram story photos that are
about wolverine and a photo with kevin
feige which is very suggestive
and hints that we could possibly be
seeing a return of hugh jackman as
wolverine in the mcu could this actually
be happening
is it too good to be true or is it just
a lot
smaller than we think it is the role
that he would play in the mcu at least
not him returning this is obviously
humongous news something that fans
really thought
wouldn't happen hugh jackman stated that
he put his claws up with logan
however there is a way that he could
return to the mcu a way that i think he
would actually find
very appealing and i actually do think
this could be suggestive
of his possible return as wolverine a
brief return
as wolverine in the marvel cinematic
universe and i'll explain it all in this
video
but if you love marvel and want to stay
up to date on all the latest news be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
so let's start off by talking about the
two photos that he shared to his
instagram story a lot of people know
digital artist boss logic he does a lot
of superhero fan work for marvel dc
star wars and disney and marvel studios
actually hire him to work on films to do
some arts on some films for example
he did the poster for spider-man far
from home well a couple of days ago
boss logic posted to instagram a picture
of wolverine's claws
just a forearm and claws and as the
caption he simply put
three however it's most likely just
representing the clause and not the
actual number
and at first this was just a really cool
post obviously boss logic has some
connections because he works directly
with people at disney and marvel studios
and some people thought this could be a
little suggestive
but most people brushed it off thinking
that it wouldn't really mean anything
however that quickly changed when a
couple of events
happened the first event was that hugh
jackman himself
actually posted to his story on his
official instagram
bosslogic's post the picture then things
started to get
a little crazy and the speculation kind
of began to run a little bit
but still hugh jackman could simply
appreciate the art that bosslogic did
and put that on his story after all
bosslogic has done art with hugh jackman
in it before
most notably the picture with jake
gyllenhaal hugh jackman and ryan
reynolds so hugh jackman knows who he is
so he could have simply been sharing the
photo that he liked however
shortly after is when things started to
get really crazy hugh jackman
out of nowhere put a picture on a story
of
him and marvel studios president kevin
feige
and this is when the entire internet
pretty much freaked out
i know i personally did because i know
that some things were being
talked about behind the scenes not too
long ago
now real quick i want to address
something that people think hugh
could have been talking about when
posting these pictures and that is the
passing of
the director richard donner the director
of the superman films the lethal weapons
franchise and the goonies and a lot of
other things
he sadly passed away yesterday and he
will be missed and a lot of people
thought that this could actually be a
tribute to him donner was a key part in
bringing the very first
x-men film to life in 2000 but here's
the problem
with this theory boss logic posted this
photo before richard donner passed away
and hugh jackman put it on his story
before richard donner passed away so it
couldn't be a tribute to him he had not
yet passed away
and even if he did why would hugh
immediately post a picture of him
and kevin feige that doesn't really make
sense either kevin feige kind of got his
start in the x-men films thanks to
richard donner's wife
lauren so again odd to post a picture of
feige and not richard donner or his wife
and then not to mention he actually did
post a little tribute to
donner he posted a screenshot of a note
that he took on his phone saying that
today we lost one of the most talented
courageous cheeky funny loyal directors
to have ever made movies
richard donner deb and i lost a great
friend lauren we send all of our love to
you
and the whole family and the hundreds of
dogs he rescued
your movies stories your laugh will
always be in our hearts very touching
tribute to somebody who clearly meant a
great deal to him but that's exactly
what this post is
a tribute to him the other posts were
not that so for those who are saying the
wolverine photo and the flag you photo
are related to richard donner i'm sorry
i just
really don't think so i actually think
this is related to the multiverse of
madness now a while ago we're not
actually sure when
but we believe it to be november of 2020
kevin feige actually called to meet with
and met with
patrick stewart professor xavier himself
and they had a talk about patrick
stewart returning
to play professor xavier in the mcu
and for those who may not have heard
about this and if you're wondering how
legitimate it is
it's a hundred percent legitimate
patrick stewart actually came out and
told
everybody what they talked about and
here's what he said and this is what he
said in january of 2021.
i met with kevin feige a couple of
months ago and we had long long
conversations and there have been moves
and suggestions
which include charles xavier here's the
problem
if we had not made logan then yes i
would probably be ready to get into that
wheelchair one more time and beat
charles xavier
but logan changed all that so he
blatantly said
that he talked to kevin feige about
returning as charles xavier however he
said
no spoiler alert for logan if you
haven't seen the film
he dies in logan and he mentioned before
that when the character died he
kind of laid it to rest he made peace
with it and he moved on
and hugh jackman kind of said that he
felt the same way and spoiler alert
again for logan he also died in the film
however kevin feige and patrick stewart
and hugh jackman are incredibly good
friends they all worked on x-men
together
they all have known each other for a
very long time and now the multiverse
exists
now it is possible for hugh jackman to
return and patrick stewart to return
without
undoing what happened in logan and quick
side note patrick stewart
as amazing as he is this could all just
kind of be a ruse from him maybe he
really is returning and he's simply
trying to throw us off
because we have heard reports in the
past that kevin feige actually really
wants some original x-men
actors to make appearances in these
multiverse films in fact when he posted
this to instagram today and everybody
started to freak out some people started
to speak up and say hey well we know
kevin foggy wanted hugh jackman to
return even if for a really quick cameo
maybe he is returning even grace
randolph from beyond the trailer tweeted
as i told you a while back
jackman's wolverine is on feige's wish
list for his mcu
multiverse and again this was talked
about a while ago and it looks like he
might
actually be returning like this could
happen and it's definitely going to be
for a small role he's not going to
return as
the wolverine with the new x-men he's
going to return in a multiversal film
most likely multiverse of madness for a
quick little cameo now i'd love to tell
you that he's actually going to pop up
in
a deadpool movie and he very well still
could because ryan reynolds is so dang
charming and of course their best
friends slash
enemies but ryan reynolds could
definitely talk him into making a
deadpool 3 cameo for sure but the
biggest problem with hugh jackman
returning as wolverine before
was he didn't want to undo what he did
in logan his death
he said that he said goodbye to the
character then didn't want to pick it
back up and go for
plenty of more years obviously training
to be wolverine is
insane and a lot of work but here's the
deal in the multiverse
he doesn't have to undo anything it's a
different version of logan the same with
patrick stewart and professor x
making a cameo in a multiverse film as
an alternate version of yourself
or a variant if you will doesn't undo
anything
at all but fans would absolutely freak
out and so far what we've heard about
multiverse of madness it
is going to be an incredible movie and
fans are going to freak out
if there was a movie where we were going
to see hugh jackman and patrick stewart
return
as wolverine and professor xavier it is
definitely multiverse of madness
and hopefully this is an actual tease
from hugh jackman we'll have to wait and
see but i am definitely hopeful at this
point that he'll make an appearance in
multiverse of madness however let me
know what you think about this how
excited would you be if hugh jackman
returned as wolverine even if it was
just for a quick
minute cameo let me know in the comments
down below and don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any future videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof